was bewildered the whole first day
that repeated and then the second day
repeated it was starting to freak him
out because it felt like gee this might
really be happening
and then the third day total freak out
how do you stop this how do i get out of
this is anyone else experiencing this
[Music]
richard have you ever felt that life is
monotonous
you know the same sort of thing day
after day after day after day
kind of like groundhog day exactly like
groundhog day so i'm assuming you've
seen
the film well not as many times as
phil connors bill murray's character the
cynical weatherman wakes up in
punxsutawney which is i don't know who
knows millions of times but yes doubles
spoiler spoilers yes if you haven't seen
the movie
it's repetitive that's kind of the point
you probably know that by now but i mean
like a lot of people that saw the movie
initially
it was just a comedy right back and
there was a funny movie yeah but over
the
over the years as i've aged and also
become wiser
um the philosophical aspects of the
meaning of life stuff what's going on
have become
sort of more appealing and for lack of a
better word the science of it the
being stuck in a time loop as today's
what if is
or as the physicists call it a causal
loop
oh a causal loop well i would uh define
a causal loop
as a theoretical proposition which of
course means
by means of either retrocausality or
time travel
a sequence of events is among the causes
of another event which
in turn among the causes of the first
mentioned event
wow that was that was incredibly natural
and authentic that's how i normally
yes it's exact right off the top of your
head but i mean yes obviously
this has become a genre in films and
it's not just groundhog day obviously
there's progress
there's a day after tomorrow which uh
with tom cruise emily blunt it's kind of
uh
uh of course you haven't seen it uh
russian doll have seen it loved it it
was an excellent series on netflix
and also the most let's say the most
recent entrant into this
time loop genre is palm springs which is
out right now have you seen that i'm
going to surprise you here and yes i
have wow
breaking news it doesn't really surprise
you because you suggested maybe that i
watch it so i did watch it and i loved
it it was great
i mean it's an interesting it's an
interesting idea for anybody to consider
okay imagine you're stuck
in a time loop and you're having to wake
up you know every day
over and over and again and again it's
been it's explored now in a whole bunch
of cool series and movies but really the
person who
wrote the book on this genre or i guess
more accurately wrote the script for
groundhog day which is you know is is
kind of the the top of the pyramid for
this genre
is of course our guest today danny rubin
danny rubin is an american screenwriter
and playwright most
famous for penning the american classic
comedy that became part of
not only popular culture but of our
everyday lexicon as well
yeah that's right groundhog day if you
haven't seen it
you've probably said it but danny isn't
just an award-winning screenwriter he's
also
one of us a science geek he got his ba
in biology from the prestigious brown
university
and once aspired to be a science
journalist himself
he later went on to teach english at a
little school called harvard
in 2016 groundhog day the musical
opened on broadway to rave reviews and
went on to be nominated for
seven tony awards
so great to have you here danny uh
welcome to what if discussed
thank you happy to be here so groundhog
day we talked about it off the top you
couldn't talk time loops
unless you're talking about this iconic
film which
again at one point was just a really
cool movie that was
you know successful at the box office
critically acclaimed and then over the
years
it started to get looked at and
scrutinized from everybody from
economists to philosophers
to hindu spiritualists to
psychologists when did this when did you
notice
that this movie was becoming more than
just a
you know a cool hollywood movie and
becoming something more
well the first signs came within the
first year when i started getting fan
mail
which screenwriters don't get
and the the fan mail was coming from
unusual places the first one
i got was from a monk in germany and
the second one was from england from a a
couple that
um followed the the kabbalah
and they thought that there was some
connections there and then a philosophy
professor and uh
pittsburgh who used to teach
that i had somehow articulated
nietzsche's eternal recurrence
that he had written about all these
things
and harold ramos also um was getting all
kinds of
notes from monks and you know buddhists
and
everybody was starting to pile on from
unusual places
so uh that's when we for me it was sort
of gratifying because i knew that there
was more meat to it than just a simple
comedy that's what was in it
and i didn't know if people were going
to get it or not and when these things
started coming back
it was great and then it was sort of a
slow burn for another 10 or 15 years
and then slowly people started using it
to refer
to the being stuck in some repetitive
cycle
um during the the iraq war
a lot of soldiers were there feeling
their days were repetitive and i started
seeing uh that uh echoed then and then
it started creeping into politics and
then it just became part of the lexicon
danny we know from uh your by
your bio that we just read that you have
a ba in biology
and uh maybe people don't know you
wanted to become a science communicator
at one point
so obviously like our audience and
everybody watching today you are
a very curious person how has the your
curiosity
shaped um your writing i think because i
i don't ever take on a script idea
for something that i already know about
i always try to find something about it
that's going to challenge me where i'm
going to have to learn
something i kind of figured out a long
time ago that
most hollywood careers involve our
screenwriting careers involve writing
scripts that don't get made
and often don't sell and so
and i knew people who were like uh man
this guy was
had lost his house had lost his
apartment had
was living out of his car and that's
when he sold his first screenplay that
changed everything
i kind of decided i wasn't going to be
that guy um
if i couldn't sell anything that was
i wasn't going to have my entire hat
hanging on that i wanted the process of
writing
to be fulfilling in my life as well so
uh i think satisfying curiosities and
things i was just toying with in my mind
or interested in
learning more about was always an
ingredient
it was interesting uh to me danny when i
read more about this
is that uh obviously bill murray and
harold ramus
had been partners and friends for a long
time they had made stripes and
caddyshack and ghostbusters
but ironically in this movie they sort
of differed in their
approach to it uh ramus wanted to go
with more the comedy tax
to it but uh apparently bill murray
wanted to explore more the philosophical
aspects
and they differed so much on this that
it ended their friendship um
made them estranged for years but in the
end do you think that it's
was that um you know the headbutting and
the pushing and pulling of you know one
philosophical
point of view one comedy point of view
is that what made this
movie uh you know resonate with people
so much
i doubt it i don't know i i think i mean
it's a good observation but i don't even
know if it's true
do you think it could have gone one way
or the other like if it was a full
comedy
would it be as as widely respected or if
it was a philosophical
uh exploration would it be the movie
that it ended and it strikes the perfect
balance yeah
well it does and we were all sort of had
skin in the game and and
harold you know he he wanted to do a
smart
clever movie and he saw that there was
that potential within this concept
and he also you know the script that i
presented to him was
not hollywood formula it was if anything
kind of
more like a an ealing studios
english movie which to me
at the time i just sort of felt um if
i've ever seen a movie
any time before then that kind of movie
is producible
it's something that somebody could make
uh it didn't occur to me that
hollywood only makes a certain kind of
movie in a certain way
and harold was aware of that and i was
pushing up against
uh standard convention and i think his
move to make it a little bit more not
even more comedic just more a harold
ramus film
you know where his sensibilities were it
wasn't just to make it funnier it was
just to make it a
the kind of film that the studio might
actually produce
and um bill and i
both sort of fought against certain
certain adolescent
instincts it wasn't just to make it
funny but
is it really the kind of funny we want
to to show
you know um bill murray
as a i don't know degenerate adolescent
type
is it necessary how much of that do you
need and so
i don't know if that was really what the
split was about i really don't know why
they were
um fighting and i think it was mostly
generated by bill
i think harold wanted everybody to get
along but he didn't know why bill was so
angry
and bill was just being uncooperative to
him
so um it interfered with the process i
guess i was the first time in the
situation i was kind of in between
and and didn't really know how to deal
with it i just
tried to be as helpful as i could to
everybody and
hope that it worked out and it's also
interesting to me
anyways that you know the character phil
connors
like the initial part where he's
resisting right obviously who wouldn't
be resisting you're waking up in the
same day every day
you're gonna freak out you're gonna
whatever cut to then you're gonna start
trying to kill yourself
whatever you're gonna do to get out of
this nightmare but then at some point he
just
kind of accepts it right and he starts
to then
even almost artistically try to create
the perfect day
and he sort of has this transition is
that part of what the
maybe if the philosophical undertones
about life
as an analogy that you know don't resist
just accept and
you find joy happiness is that fair to
say
well it's fair i don't i don't know if
it's limited by that
i i swear i've heard from so many people
whose experience of the movie is so
different from each other
in terms of the specific things that
they are able to drill in on
you know i set it up like an experiment
without any expectations i didn't know
where it was gonna go
but i thought of i mean what if
perfectly what if a guy was stuck
repeating the same day
and i just put myself in that situation
and i thought the first
day it would just feel weird and
disorienting and we're all socialized
to try and get along and not create
upset
and so he just sort of was bewildered
the whole first day
that repeated and then the second day
repeated it was starting to freak him
out because it felt like gee this might
really be happening
and then the third day total freak out
how do you stop this how do i get out of
this is anyone else experiencing
this how you know you do your scientific
inquiry what are all of the
the boxes what could this possibly be
let's theorize
um obviously his goal is to get out of
it and just stop it to make it go away
and when after he discovers even death
isn't going to stop it
that's it's not that he accepts it but
that he stops fighting
how do i get out of it you know good way
to put it
that and starts looking at how do i live
how do i live can can i just ask you how
much personally
do you wonder about the existential
aspects of life like i'm guessing
you live in new mexico so you probably
spend a lot of nights gazing up
staring at the stars surrounded by a
rich indigenous history
like there must be a lot of uh pondering
in your life
um why do you believe you wrote this
movie in the end was there a bigger
significance
to it than what you thought at the time
i i don't know i
i you know you can always look back at
these things and dig in and say well
obviously because of the kind of person
i was then it came out
this way but very clearly
we were not trying to
preach to anybody about anything um we
were just telling a story
i was just telling a story and i was
aware of all the
the humanistic ramifications and
and the existential situation i mean
just the fact that
you know the studio kept trying to give
us a reason for his being stuck in the
time
loop because that conform to their
idea of storytelling and and this is how
this kind of comedy story works and
my feeling was if you don't have an
explanation of how we got here you make
it just
we put everybody into that seat because
none of us know how we got here
and none of us know what the rules are
and we ask you know we look to our
parents and teachers and leaders and
civilization and other people to try and
figure out
what are the rules what are the limits
and we all figure out that we have to
find love and
make something of ourselves in life yeah
and i
i believe that i already had that
kind of perspective going into writing
it
so it doesn't surprise me that it ended
up there
and frankly harold is a very um
thoughtful philosophical questioning guy
he
he goes after it or went after it more
in terms of
experience and reading a lot of books
and and getting as much knowledge and
hearing other people's perspective and
joining men's groups and being part of a
you know
uh active in inclu
i wanted to say inquisition isn't the
right word inquiry i guess
into all of these great issues um i'm
not quite so
formal about it as you say i move to the
kind of place where you notice the
beauty of the universe constantly
i uh and the the cultural diversity
makes you wonder okay what are the
limits what do different people believe
what
other cultures adapted in ways of
dealing with life
and one of the things that i think most
people in santa fe have in common
is the general appreciation for moment
to moment of life and
some thoughtfulness and a little bit
less ambition
um and it just is a slightly
quieter and less anxious place from
which to explore whatever it is i'm
thinking about
yeah sounds beautiful maybe we could all
use uh
getting stuck in a time loop uh just
trying to figure some of those things
out and certainly
i'd take a week in santa fe right now as
well but uh
for peter and i it's been a great a real
pleasure we're massive fans of the movie
so thanks for giving us the opportunity
to sort of wake up and
punch zatani again one more time
uh what what is going on with you these
days i know that the musical groundhog
day of the musical it was a massive hit
and won tons of tony's in
or nominated for tony's what are you up
to these days and
and what can we where can we follow what
you're doing
oh kind of you to ask i i'm not
promoting myself in any big way so
there's no
you know i have a website i never visit
um so i
welcome anyone else to do that too but
i'm working on a stage play if that ever
comes up
you can look for it but the world of
theater is closed for the time being so
you know don't hold your breath um in
the meantime i'm a songwriter i write a
lot of songs
my amusement and for that of my friends
but i'm starting to
reach into the community a little bit
more and maybe you'll hear
hear some of that at some point well
thanks
thanks for uh asking um
i'm always working on movie and
television series ideas maybe something
will pop up someday
perfect great to hear from you danny
thanks for joining us today appreciate
it
i appreciate you guys enjoy super cool
getting to talk to danny rubin
uh like groundhog day is one of my
favorite movies and i'm you've seen it
like
got to be a top 10 movies i've seen it a
thousand times yes and so if you have
seen it a lot you would remember
that bill murray obviously after waking
up in punxsutawney like i don't know a
million times he starts to get
you know disillusioned suicidal
disheveled
even he shows up i think to do the
weather hit one day in his pajamas
unshaven you know what he could have
used what could he have used richard
how about the lawnmower 3.0
how's that for a segway great it's from
manscaped who's our sponsor today
and uh speaking of disheveled i think
you remember at the
at the beginning of this i thought i was
gonna at the beginning of kovid
the pandemic yes i thought i was gonna
grow a little bit of a beard because i
thought we yeah
we'll be home for like three weeks yes
nobody thought it was gonna be five
months yes cut
two five months later yeah so uh i got
one of these from
from manscape and the lawnmower 3.0
and it's the perfect personal grooming
device
that i use for this i've got it it's got
a couple different uh
settings on it you can go number two or
number one well relative to a couple of
episodes ago where you were
right it was a little bit bushier so
this week i did the number one
you can hear it going i don't know if i
don't know if you can hear how's that on
the skin it's great on the skin it's
uh they've got this nick free technology
so you don't cut yourself like you used
to cut yourself
yes not on their product yeah but on
other people's products
you would cut yourself so this has got
nick free technology and the blades
it's some sort of patented blade i know
exactly what they what they term it but
you get replacement blades every three
months
when you get the perfect package 3.0
essentials kit which we both received
and
thank you manscape because beyond just
this got a whole bunch of other
essential oils some other cool stuff
yeah there was a there was no not
essential oils but there was a
anti-chafing deodorant and a uh a
moisturizing
spray uh that helped out as well as a
free pair of underwear
a travel bag and like i say you get the
the free blades
are not free plates but you get
replacement blades every three months
when you get the package
how you liking the new beard i'm gonna
have to go in the washroom and finish
this off
if you guys would like to get something
like this you can get 20
off at manscaped.com when you use the
promo code what if so go to manscape.com
and use the promo code what if and what
if
what if and get one of these things and
clean yourself
up so we get to return one more time
to punk satani pennsylvania
with uh danny one more time that one
more time
um a couple of cool takeaways
especially what i thought like his last
answer was really interesting and
thoughtful and philosophical
but it it did surprise me that really
out of the gate
they he you know he talked about getting
fan letters you know back in the day
there was no emails literally got fan
letters
mentioned a german monk which is is kind
of an oxymoron you think
like you don't think a lot of german
monks but that it started to
almost out of the gate be something that
people were responding to
from a philosophical standpoint more
than just hey that was a really funny
movie
right because it's all about it is all
about then philosophical
uh point of view and i thought it was
very funny that he got more
uh letters from monks yes like more
monks all the monks in the world are
like all of a sudden he's
he's got pen pals but it's interesting
because if you if you you know like
you you have you know whether it's the
hindu religion talking about karma
you know reincarnation there's a lot of
aspects when you start to look at
you know buddhism philosophy in general
that that you come back to this idea of
as he talked about it was very
well worded the way he put it i asked
about
bill murray accepting his fate and he
sort of turned it i can't remember his
exact wording but he wasn't he said it's
not so much accepting
he just stopped resisting it right right
and
yeah just sort of went with the flow and
was kind of present for that which is
something you would hear
you know whether it's a new age deepak
chopra or eckhart tolle or if you're
listening to somebody talk about
you know buddhism you know from a
theological perspective
yeah i think it's probably uh a movie
that resonated with the monks
because it was probably one of the first
movies that talked about existentialism
it was probably one of the first movies
that you know dove into those
sort of topics and since then it's been
become a very popular
trope or yes subject tons of movies like
tons of movies not necessarily just
stuck in a time warp but also just
thinking about your existential
existence on the earth
and interestingly like groundhog day
when you when people use the term right
and you know it's part of
our lexicon now like people that have
never seen the movie will reference oh
man this week has felt like groundhog
day and they mean
obviously the same thing over and over
again
referring to the movie which is negative
but there's also
aspects of it that are i think positive
in that
like you know he initially you go
through these things in your life that
you're like oh my god whatever
it's always after the fact that you look
back and say
well that's what ultimately got me to
sort of be more aware take notes and say
okay what do i got to switch up here
because whatever i'm doing it ain't
working and what do we know about one of
the definitions
of insanity it's doing the same thing
over and over again
and expecting different results well
if you like this episode maybe you'll
like to groundhog day it
and go back to the beginning and watch
it all over again which we appreciate
keep groundhog day
yeah or maybe you just want to dig a
little deeper into the subject and if
that is the case
we'll go a little deeper next when we
speak with ryan wasserman
professor of philosophy at western
washington university
about the paradoxes of time travel but
you're gonna have to click
on the link in the description below to
get to it
because it's an extended audio version
so join us for that
we'll talk more about time paradoxes
time loops and uh maybe finding love and
getting out of our time
loop we'll see you again next time on
what if discussed